so how much will marvel let you say what
can you tell us
i
they they i i try not to say basically
anything
so you don't give them at all and then
just say oh it's a continuation of both
of our characters
[Laughter]
really good at taking these kinds of i
feel like you're very good you're good
at navigating your things god now the
heat's on i i i'm excited it's the
weirdest thing you're out very very
publicly talking about a film you can't
talk about that's that's hard an odd job
to do but you know it's it's all part of
acting i guess you've got to be good at
teasing get people excited about it
little yeah saying something without
saying much at all i know like
[Laughter]
this is an epic film fans of sam raimi
are going to love it there's schlock
horror jump horror and some revelations
that will blow your socks off um it
deserves to be seen in the theater
there's a great new character in it as
well as wonderful returning characters
and new character in this part of the
mcu as in we haven't teamed up before
scarlet witch so there's a lot to enjoy
i wish i just kept him with me
that's what's interesting is i've never
really thought about that when it comes
to like these kind of these kinds of
movies like you can't you don't want to
reveal it you don't want to be a spoiler
alert but it's like you're here to
promote it that's really hard yeah we're
like how entertaining are we talking
about nothing you're going to enjoy
everything that i can't tell you right
now um so are you surprised sometimes
when you watch the marvel movies like
you're in are you surprised you ever
because y'all don't get to see
everything right
yes no i i i think especially because i
come from avengers land that becomes
even more secretive and they if you want
to if you want to read it you have to
read it on an ipad or at least for me i
had to i don't know what your privilege
was and and then it started to be that i
only got my own pages and so i have no
idea what i mean
when we filmed infinity war we showed up
to set at the end of the movie
and they said okay so the script pages
are wrong you guys are all going to turn
to dust
sorry for people who haven't seen it but
it was a very long time ago it's your
fault at this point like whatever
so you got there thinking you were and
then you found out you were gonna go to
into dust yes they told us this like on
the day and we all were just ready to
shoot that day and we're like okay well
i guess and they're like i guess i just
die yeah i guess we're just gonna
disintegrate
i i was so shocked at that i'm so
excited i love how i love how these
movies unfold especially anyway so why
do you think doctor strange is so moody
this is my thing because because here's
because here's my thing this is why i'm
asking because like i get your origin
story like i get why you were kind of
jerk um but anyway but like the doctor
situation but i'm like why are you so
moody you're like the most powerful like
why are you so moody
is it because you don't have a love
interest because
it might be something to do
you know every one of these films is
like therapy for these characters and
okay often therapy with themselves hint
and i think you just have to watch this
one to see but he learns a lot during
this film okay because i'm just i don't
even know i haven't seen it but i'm just
like throwing it out there to writers in
the world like i would love for you to
have a love interest again anyway so
i'm like i just noticed someone might be
back in this film and i'm like come on
but i don't know what's happening um but
how do you
how do you think um he'd do in therapy
i think pretty uh would he just do this
and disappear yeah probably yeah just
skip it
um if he had to uh i think he would be
pretty snarky and defensive i think it
would be quite a long slog
um but he'll get to it he'll get to he's
not above learning i think we've reached
the stage now with him as a character
where he's so omniscient and omnipresent
and omni everything that he needs he
needs a check he needs to check in for
sure so this is very much what the
film's about it's sort of
his evolution uh is is very much part of
the story so so how did you find out
about miss marvel whatsapp
is that real yeah my aunt was part of
your life right now okay keep going it's
crazy my aunt was part of a group chat
that she never opens one day she decided
to and there was like the miss marvel
casting call and it was like a blank
page miss marvel sent hedgehog and
resumed this email super sketchy so
obviously i did it
but no i was a huge marvel fan in high
school i read all the comics i was a
marvel nerd my entire life surrounded
marvel and now people actually have to
listen when i talk about it because i
like work you get paid for it now it's
great it's amazing but um yeah it's
awesome though that you always loved it
and then you could your first role is
like something that you loved as a kid
yeah you're still a kid to me but you
know i was like i could be your mom
look we can how do you get a career
online it's like yeah that's amazing
your aunt went on live daily yeah what's
that and it was like this is the
brownest way this could have happened
like for south asians whatsapp is our
home
it's costco and what's that
you're funny too
thank you very much
is it true that you gave marvel feedback
on like all the marvel movies i got to
be honest everything that happened in my
first year at marvel was such a blur but
yeah i probably did i like every time i
see a new movie i'm like texting kevin
or victoria like hey so next time
maybe try this instead but like you're
on the right track
oh my god they like can't say no to me
now did you have any school
no i got cast on the last day of high
school
what is your life perfect graduation
present considering i didn't get one
because of kovitz so
yeah well there you did though we don't
feel real bad yeah no one feels bad for
you right now so wait one of the coolest
things though is you are marvel's first
muslim superhero that's like really cool
too does that
it's so cool does it feel because the
the inclusivity is awesome does it do
you feel pressure because of that
because you're like holding something
down like all by yourself right now
nope nope
i love you no i mean like you know
what's great a catholic a muslim and a
jew we should go a walk into a bar
christian
well let's walk into a bar i know
something really funny right now that's
a great joke i love it it's coming can't
no but there's there's a lot of pressure
with being the first of anything i just
i don't think about it like i can't wake
up every morning be like you're the
first muslim pakistani superhero do good
okay for your people
but uh like no it's just
the superhero part is so cool and it's
just like working with my idols and i'm
just there's so much inspiration and
then like representation for me behind
the camera like all the creatives on our
show have such a
emotional attachment to this character
into the story and they're bringing so
much of that and i think that's just why
i'm here congrats on hot guy were you so
stoked i know all of us were i love all
these shows breaking off yeah yeah i
thought i thought it'd be just a great
opportunity to uh you know instead of
two-hour film and just go into like a
longer form of storytelling i didn't
know it's gonna be six hours i thought
it might have been six or eight but i'm
quite sure somewhere in there yeah i
just thought it'd be a it's a better
sort of introduction to
you know that world you know and it's um
it does have a lot of christmas spirit
to it and it is set in new york at
christmas and oh my god it's wonderful
at christmas time in new york yeah yeah
yeah no it's sort of the backdrop for
the show and
um yeah it's good man i learned i
learned a lot and had a great time doing
it and some really great people well all
of us nerdy fans that love avengers we
were very stoked
i'm like literally like it's the one
time when my kids will watch me but
they're five and seven and i'm like i'm
like be quiet it's on no matter
what they get are you is eva into it
your daughter is she intended well this
is the thing yeah you know because she's
eight now and i've been doing it for a
long time uh most of the stuff she could
never see because i do pretty kind of
heavy stuff typically
um so we got to go to the premiere she
got look she knew i was on her pajamas
since i was two she was two right but
she didn't know what really meant all
the friends of school knew and all right
but she's never seen anything so i gotta
actually take her to to see the show and
probably the highlight of of my career
for sure if not my life was really
wonderful thing to share with with my
daughter and yeah um and to see her do
you feel like you know she's proud of my
dad
my dad's so dope
yeah your daughter's brownie like that's
so cool because she's eight right yeah
so that's only gonna last so long is it
true that you dressed as hawkeye when
you went to ava's school uh yo that was
the idea because i never had any any
took anything from uh any of the uh
marvel movies and i so they asked me to
do like the valet thing to pick you know
with the yeah did people you drive up to
the
in your car with the kid in it and they
need to be escorted to the classroom
yeah so i figured if i'm going to do it
i'm going to just let this hawk out the
hawkeye is valley i'm going to like
really you know plus it i'm going to get
after it
but you're awesome so by the time the
costume came around it was um
it was halloween already so my daughter
asked me will you just wear that for
halloween and so i did so i went to we
went to a little party with like 30 kids
and i was just making pizzas for them
and dinosaur and security while they did
were the kids just freaking
trick-or-treating i would have just been
the kid just like sitting there looking
at you like how is this happening how's
this my life yeah it's it's a weird
thing it's a weird thing but it's also
just you know one of the coolest things
ever as well what would typically be
annoying um
uh for me in in life it becomes the most
wonderful blessing
yeah yeah to have kids like you know uh
light up guy yeah can light up and smile
and bring some joy to people like it's
it's a beautiful thing and it makes me
really happy oh that's so cool i'd love
that for you i want to wear a superhero
costume
it looks like that you practice at your
house your archery skills at your house
i want to show this footage here this is
pretty cool
so
is this how you
what kind of what kind of major
expensive bow and arrow situation was
yeah yeah that was my daughter's little
choice we were uh yeah just being you
know
being bored i love like in my brain this
is a superhero at home just like i'm
totally like look i'm so bored
so what memories of chadwick do you have
do you have any great ones uh let's see
what was maybe about
15 years ago i was i was given
thankfully grateful for a honorary phd
from howard university oh wow yeah so i
went there that's amazing both there
thanks and uh he was he was my guide he
was my student guy like before he was
before anything and everything yeah
he was an actor there he was an actor
there what a full circle moment
did he tell you that whenever he told me
that at the at the opening party at the
premier party and i was like
you cold water
i can't hold water you know but he
didn't tell you the whole time and we
sat next to each other every morning in
the makeup chair you know as we're
getting our lines and our accents and
our work together for the day and uh oh
my gosh
amazing i would have reminded me of that
i would have had to have been like what
you do yeah oh my gosh that's so cool
though i love those full circle moments
that's really really cool amazing
amazing well i have to ask you about
this because i'm obsessed with marvel um
so you're playing kate bishop and
hawkeye that's amazing
what
did you okay in my world if i were an
actor this would be like my dream role
so because okay so like i'm just saying
i'm not an actor so i don't wanna but i
just love watching them but is it were
you freaking out when you got the call
everybody wants to play these roles
right yeah yeah freaking out and then
you get in the door and then you're part
of all of them oh no it's a why and i
still feel like every time i do
something i feel that way like it's the
most when i met uh on the project for
the first time i
that alone was like the most wild
experience i like went to the studio and
i felt like the coolest person ever i
was like going underground and through
these separate gates and all these
things it was like so hush-hush and i
was like i don't even have the time yeah
vip yeah this is wild so um
it's it's been a very very fun
experience i'm so excited to be playing
a character that is so loved and i can't
wait for people to meet him oh my god
i love him
do you have any bone arrow skills like
can you or none are we one of those
actors that was like yes i'm amazing at
that and then you get there um yeah no i
actually i was uh i had um
i was that person i i spent so much time
watching videos uh of
uh just all levels of archery so i felt
like i was like okay i have an idea of
like what the form looks like you know
people like like watching a gymnast and
being like okay by the way
they go up to the line and they you know
everybody's got their little like they
take their deep breath or they like do
like a weird little like twitch or
something i'm like oh yeah for sure so i
went and took my first archery lesson um
with this really wonderful uh instructor
and it was like a two-hour lesson and i
was ready to go again i was like
watching videos on the way there and i
was just i i had my stance down i was
ready to go i get there and he
talks for like an hour and like 40
minutes wait and you're not just like
it's right there it's on the table i can
just i can just you know get it and go
but it was amazing because he like you
know was educating me on the on the you
know technical side of it all and i'm
okay great but i just wanted to like get
going so by the time i actually picked
up the bow and arrow i
i will say he complimented me on the
form
[Applause]
he was surprised that i had never done
it before
um but i had a lot to learn
that would have killed me an hour and a
half i'd be like
wrap it up brutal yeah brutal and i kept
like i kept i was like you know trying
so hard to yeah i was like i had my mask
on i was yawning under my mask i'm like
this is so bad
um but the whole time i'm like throwing
little nods to the yeah that's i i
wonder what that feels like you know
what you're talking about you know yeah
i wonder yeah
you know i could just feel it right yeah
yeah that's some mr miyagi stuff right
there you have to like do all this other
stuff before you get to so um i know you
know selma right
of course yeah yes i was asking i'm like
sometimes when y'all are in movies
together you don't have scenes together
so i was always i was like well i was
like did y'all meet and you did
yeah but we had a lot of fun together
yeah i love it i'm so excited about this
film so um who was the most fun on set
i am sitting right next to her
i have to say just so you know her
middle name is p for party party girl
yes she actually hosted this fab
christmas party for everyone she
actually cooked for everybody
you did for everybody else usually
people hire that out and there's a lot
of eternals huh
there's a lot of oh that's what i'm
saying but it was homey we made like a
real christmas you know homey with
friends and relaxed and yeah all right
tequila okay i'll give you i'll give you
my number i like lucky food and fun um
eternals um it's it's full of
representation we were talking about
that earlier it's so cool so how did you
feel about representation in film and tv
whenever you were a kid
well i have to say when growing up as a
little kid i really didn't see a lot of
myself on tv or the big screen it was
more like just bits and pieces here and
there and you know i saw a deaf woman on
sesame street linda bove yeah linda the
librarian right
you know i saw her and she was like me
but
one another woman who really inspired me
was frida kahlo
and my mom at the time was a grad
student
and she in art education and she focused
in on frida and i just remember seeing
this beautiful strong talented mexican
woman who just claimed her space in a
world that was not ready for a mexican
female artist
and so it really inspired me that's
that's so cool
while we were shooting
she was a huge inspiration to me oh
that's so cool i love being in my life
i will take that with me forever yeah so
i mean how did you find out that you got
the role
well i remember it was valentine's day
and i was driving actually to get a
pizza shop to get some pizza for my boys
and then i got an email and that's how i
found out i had to pull over
and
i couldn't believe it i was going to be
a superhero
and you know waiting for somebody to
jump in and say psych just kidding
psych
um so lauren could you tell us about
your character in eternals
well makari um you may already know
she's a speedster she's really fast
she's traveled all over the world i
don't even know how many times and she
loves art she loves books and really she
just loves
those earth people
i love so do all of them not love earth
people is that what you're getting at
what she said
no more than others some more than
others
that's a david ends in why in my world
[Music]
you